hey guys Ryan right here I have been
waiting for this trailer to drop for the
longest [ __ ] time now
Mission Impossible five some people
really prefer the first one but it was
mission impossible 3 for me that was
really the run 3 for me I like to go
peepee oh my god I like to eat [ __ ]
this is a live streaming event right now
fans are jumping in I'm gonna be
basically doing a live reaction for this
I unfortunately can't show the fans the
mission of possible 5 video so all you
guys are gonna have to look at my face
the entire time instead see there's a
laptop right here I'm gonna keep the
laptop in the shot this guy who's
directing it he's worked with Tom Cruise
several times before and just tomorrow
is one of my favorite [ __ ] movies of
last year but at the same time I wasn't
a big fan of his direction in Jack
Reacher I know Tom Cruise was satisfied
with it I'm [ __ ] stoked and I heard
Alec Baldwin's in this do I want you to
choose your next words very carefully
where is hunt nice
nice
Betty Lisa where are you The Syndicate
is real the protonation media oh [ __ ]
whoa that was really him hanging from
the [ __ ] airplane holy [ __ ] you could
tell that was him and you could tell
that was what I mean if that's CGI
that's amazing [ __ ] CGI well it's so
different watching the trailer was
knowing a whole bunch of people are
watching right now it feels like your
night the [ __ ] group with a bunch of
people so your energy gets jacked up
what I want to do is get you guys asking
questions and hearing your opinions on
it and we can go back and forth what we
thought of the trailer all of us I
thought that'd be really fun like an
interactive experience I love the tone
of it so far it seems like a hybrid of
like part three and four because four
brought it back to the fun spy you know
espionage type of vibe but three had
more of a dark tone and it felt more
personal and more intense so I feel like
they're taking both of the best mission
impossible is I'm putting putting it
together like it looks executed very
well you know Tom Cruise has his
darkness going on in his intensity I
loved seeing what's going on with Simon
Pegg how he's you know more involved in
the actual field like he's dressed up
like a British spy as his glasses and
Alec Baldwin playing a tough guy at the
agency
what other role would you want the guy
to do and Tom Cruise is so [ __ ] sexy
I totally suck this guy's guy yeah I
know I had my doubts but seeing the the
way it's all captured it looks like a
darker version of ghost Protocol
that's pretty [ __ ] sweet and Tom
Cruise is here doesn't look that bad I
thought I wasn't gonna like it based off
of still but I like his hair I like his
hair kind of looks like a little
Catholic boy but now I get it anyway
guys so let's chime in what do you guys
what did you guys think of the trailer
so apparently this was a teaser now I
feel like a [ __ ] idiot what you guys
think of the teaser that's easier to me
it seemed like it give you a perfect
trailer the rogue nation title I am in
Japan though yeah the road
rogue nation rogue ninja I was reading
someone has a ninja
rogue nation is such a cool title yes
the idea to of having a Anti agency
that's it's pretty much like you know
the IMF is that what they're called
impossible MIT mission or is it IMT
IMF but having Tom Cruise's agency have
like an equal agency but they're the bad
guys
that's a clever plot actually that's
what I mean it brings it back to feeling
a little bit more personal they call me
KK P said I love how Tom Cruise ups the
ante in his stunts last movie it was
climbing the tallest building this time
is on AFN airplane whoa [ __ ] yeah I mean
Tom Cruise keeps getting older but what
makes him cool is he's really trying to
prove that he's not old and he keeps
doing life dangerous things you know
putting his life on edge for the sake of
entertaining us to be like I really am
not old please still let me have a
career no Tom Cruise is this [ __ ] he's
one of my favorite actors Eliana ramirez
said I love you oh is that other lady
gonna live there I have a girlfriend so
no NATO del Toro
said it was awesome but it feels like
it's trying to imitate what Brad Bird
did and ghost Protocol I don't think
about imitate I think it's more about
like honoring the tone but I can see why
you might feel that way southern play
says [ __ ] you and your pubic hair why
would you want to [ __ ] my pubic hair
Billy Lawrence said the plot to us is
that the rogue nation is actually the
real rejects who are rejected from the
IMF their leader Ryan price is the main
antagonist and there's an epic showdown
late in the film that's true and then
Tom Cruise makes me suck his dick in
revenge
Spaulding's rejects said would you let
Tom Cruise give you a rim job absolutely
I don't care what conflict it would
cause of my girlfriend Brandon Egan said
something perfect every year Tom gets
older in his action movies he gets
younger so freakin true Ryan Fitzsimmons
said I love how the missions are always
possible what if this one is actually
impossible and they just go okay well
[ __ ] it let's get a new career that
would be a funny meet like vine or
something
I'm going to end this I've been
recording now for quite some time so
thank you guys for tuning in and helping
the review this is why I like it because
you know like a lot of the time when I
do a trailer review a lot of questions
come in and so I don't really know like
what are other things that people might
want me to discuss thank you guys for
tuning in - by the way I [ __ ] love
you guys 90,000 was [ __ ] amazing so
seriously thank you take care bye bye